bienvenue sur cette nouvelle vidéo de la
société ecc chose promise chose due dans
le cadre de cette semaine de la classe
inversée je vais vous proposer des
séquences de cours que j'ai déjà réalisé
que j'ai déjà testé en classe avec des
élèves et qui utilisent vraiment tous
les atouts de la classe d'inverser mais
surtout du numérique alors souvenez vous
de la première vidéo de cette semaine
pour mettre les élèves en activité
d'apprentissage
c'est très important mais avant toute
chose le générique génériques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
cette séquence s'inscrit finalement dans
un dispositif qu'on avait mis en place
des gens 5e puisqu'en 5e on avait déjà
étudié la politique est donc ici l'objet
d'études c'était les présidentielles
françaises mais notre problématique et
n'était pas forcément la politique
puisqu'on l'avait travail en 5e nous on
s'intéressait cette année-là au discours
de campagne électorale donc quels sont
les discours finalement que tiennent les
différents candidats à une campagne
électorale ici la présidentielle
française la question vraiment et
l'hypothèse c'était on se disait mais
tient les candidats de gauche et de
droite doivent sans doute mobiliser des
représentations des images différentes
en fonction évidemment de leur peau leur
positionnement sur l'échiquier politique
donc d'abord on a dû réactiver mais ça
s'est fait de manière très classique
tout ce qui est l'axé gauche droite
c'est quoi qu'elles sont laids les
images ou des représentations liées à
l'univers de gauche à l'univers de
droite ça c'était vraiment la mise en
route
puis les élèves ont dû déjà utilisé les
outils numériques pour rechercher de
l'information
évidemment moi j'étais derrière pour
leur dire ça ça va ça il faut que tu
précisent les sources que tu as utilisé
ça est ce que tu es sûr de la source
donc là sur un forum tout simplement
c'était un groupe facebook puisque à
l'époque on n'avait pas encore google
classroom si ça se faisait maintenant ça
serait sur google classroom sur le
groupe facebook il partageait vraiment
d'un des morceaux de discours alors on
était vraiment dans les temps de la
campagne
il y avait plein de choses qui arrivent
et les élèves étaient très axé là-dessus
puisqu'on avait déjà quelques français
et puis il y avait aussi des élèves qui
étaient très intéressés par l'ape la
chose politique
et puis bon c'était des choses
finalement dont on parlait beaucoup et
donc qu'ils essayaient de retrouver des
morceaux des passages de meetings des
passages d'émissions télé alors on a une
élève qui était française et qui nous a
amenés ben plein de brochures plein de
programmes qui sont envoyées en fait aux
français de belgique aux expatriés
le mystère je pose des affaires
étrangères français on voit comme ça les
brochures des dix candidats donc on
avait vraiment de la matière brute comme
ça de la matière première et ça ça a été
là vraiment la première phase on a amené
des mâts des matériaux comme ça on a
exploré à tout va
le rôle du prof c'était juste de guider
les élèves dans leurs recherches
ça c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
s'est prolongé tout au long de la
recherche
évidemment on n'a pas arrêté quand on
n'a qu'un nombre commencé l'analyse on a
continué à alimenter évidemment nos
travaux donc c'est un petit peu si vous
voulez la déjà classe inversé ou en tout
cas un dispositif dans lequel on met de
la classe inversée ce que vous avez
compris que la classe inversée
finalement c'est une petite partie d'un
dispositif où on essaie de mettre les
élèves en activité la classe inversée
finalement n'a pas interrompu la
recherche et c'est un petit peu comme
faire la cuisine quand vous faites la
cuisine c'est une image que leurs
proches reprend souvent pour expliquer
aux élèves finalement notre manière de
travailler
vous n'allez pas faire la sauce à
spaghetti et puis seulement attendre que
la sauce à spaghetti soit prête pour
lancer l'eau des pâtes non vous allez
peut-être lancer le départ alors que
votre sauce à spaghetti fini cuir ont
fait plusieurs choses à la fois en
cuisinant pendant que quelque chose est
en train de me jeter on prépare autre
chose quand quelque chose et réserver au
frigo on fait autre chose abeilles si
c'est la même chose donc ça notre
première activité c'était cette activité
de recherche mais qui était vraiment
100% la responsabilité des élèves
si on peut dire parce qu'évidemment moi
j'étais toujours là pour contrôler ça y
est arrivé le moment où il a fallu
injecter de la théorie et trouver des
modèles finalement qui allait nous
permettre d'analyser ses discours il
s'agissait pas de faire ça à la manière
du café du commerce
personnellement j'ai horreur de ça donc
on a eu des idées deux outils théoriques
qui nous ont été proposés enfin qui ont
été proposées aux f que j'ai proposé aux
élèves
tout d'abord il ya une classe inversée
c'était vraiment une vidéo sur les
idéologies
je me base sur un bouquin je vais vous
le maître ici en incrustation vous aurez
aussi le détaillant aux commentaires
donc là c'était vraiment de la casse
inverser la manière classique avec de la
vidéo mais voici une classe inversée
avec des choses que les élèves devaient
lire et finalement je me suis basé sur
un résumé que j'ai trouvé ce wikipedia
d'un bouquin or le bouquin abordés il
s'agit de mythe et mythologie de caen de
politique phare dont de raoul girardet
qui est historien mais en fait il y
avait vraiment des passages vraiment
intéressant
ils nous proposent différents mythes le
mythe du sauveur de l'homme providentiel
finalement qui arrive on a vu que ça
correspondait bas macron par exemple
mais aussi d'autres mythes comme le
mythe du de l'âge d'or c'était mieux
avant là c'est un mythe que mélenchon
mobilisé que marine le pen mobilisés
donc ça a été les classes inversée en
plus de ça j'ai injecté au fur et à
mesure du cheminement différents
documents que les élèves de devait
devait consulter comme ça hors classe
mais après on en discutait avant de se
mettre au travail en classe ont discuté
de ces éléments que j'apportais je vous
met tous ces éléments ils seront ici
dans la description dans le descriptif
de la vidéo est donc une fois bien armé
de tous ces éléments
je ne sais plus si j'avais fait un petit
questionnaire google forme et bien là on
était passé à la phase d' analyse donc
avec les vidéos les tracts électoraux
qu'ils avaient collecté ils ont utilisé
ces outils théoriques et ils les ont
analysés et ça on a fait ça avec un
google docs
donc nous étions tous collecter
connecter sur le même document les
tâches étaient partagés l'un s'occupe et
de nathalie arthaud lo de s'occuper de
jacques cheminade puis à s'occuper de
macro lot de fillon l'hôte de benoît
hamon et chacun construisez finalement
son analyse au fur et à mesure mais moi
j'étais connecté sur le même document de
que hélas a pu être vraiment intéressant
parce que je regardais en direct ce qui
faisait traitement lui dire tiens toi
ici c'est un peu apprécié qu'ils disent
plutôt ce concept là tu n'applique pas
bien concept et là on a vraiment
construit une synthèse commune que je
vais vous partagez évidemment je voulais
mettre ici aussi à l'écran et là on a eu
vraiment du travail collaboratif quoi et
au final c'était vraiment quelque chose
je pense que les éléphants n'atteignant
j'étais très fier de ce qu'ils avaient
fait du niveau d' analyse qu'ils avaient
atteint donc voilà un peu le dispositif
il faut savoir que tout ce dispositif là
finalement il nous permettait de faire
de l'observation et de la mobilisation
était ok
quels éléments je vais reprendre et la
c3
tout en faisant de la c4 parce que la c4
la communication donc vivre un rapport
écrit en même temps pour évaluer
je me suis basé sur l'historique
finalement des modifications et là on a
dans un historique je voudrais ça dans
une prochaine vidéo
en fait avec un gourou blocks vous
pouvez avoir accès à toutes les
révisions notre bien sûr tout ce
dispositif s'intègre dans le programme
on a parlé des compétences mais il ya
aussi quelque chose d'important ce sont
les concepts qui ont été mobilisés au
niveau des institutions là y en avait
très peur parce que je n'avais pas leur
faire étudier la vème république
quoique on en a beaucoup parlé des
institutions françaises ça leur permet
un petit peu de faire du système
politique compte comparez donc ça peut
être intéressant puisqu'ils ont vu la
belgique en cinquième mais surtout on a
vu trois grands concepts alors le mythe
en général qu'est ce qu'un mythe limites
politiques en particulier avec ses 4000
qui sont proposés par raoul girardet et
les idéologies
je vous remercie en tout cas pour votre
attention je vous souhaite une bonne
continuation et à très bientôt
nous nous sommes tous
[Musique]